oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah this show is brought to
you by datsu Sarah go to dsgear.com and
use code word Joey to get five percent
off of their extremely high quality
functional gear made with hemp textiles
they have bags geese rash guards and
much much more go to dsgear.com and use
code word Joey to get five percent off
and go to onit.com and use cohort Church
to save 10 on all the great optimization
products like Alpha brand new mood
stream tech immune and shroom Tech sport
oh [__]
just when you thought it was safe
[__]
church is back
[Music]
there you go
a little bad company loosen things up
Uncle Joey Lee Syed
yeah little music
a little Sunday night filling
happy Memorial's Day [__]
for all the soldiers out there you bad
[__]
they're the baby
listen to that [__] voice [__]
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here thank you for the
special edition Memorial Day podcast
here we want to get out of the way we
don't want to [__] with your day
tomorrow we got my main man Dean Del
Rizzi with a pulled muscle in his
[__] throat [__] sound good it's
crazy muscle hookup pose and [__] only
two people pull that muscle hookers and
singers which one of you yeah man it's
so true it's so weird like you just like
I was supposed to do a podcast really
last week and I just wake up and or my
neck it it hit the left muscle on my
neck was just completely felt like it
was paralyzed I was like whoa what the
[__] is this and all day I was waiting
to do the podcast I was like I don't
think I can go do this it's just flared
up and I was like oh that's cancer you
know everything's cancer everything's
[__] cancer Everything is Everything
is for me everything I had a fat ball in
my neck right in here yeah and whenever
I would go to The Comedy Store and I
would talk and get excited the fat ball
which was
it took me a [__] month and a half to
go down to that doctor she decided yeah
cause you're scared right [__]
petrified I had one of those fat balls
right here in my arm right you're
petrified you don't know what the [__]
to hear and he went and they did some
tests he said it was malignant no cancer
and I had to wait six weeks and [__]
go down there and that the whole time
you don't know what to do so would it
grow like right away or what did it
throughout the day so I would feel it in
there I would feel like just the top
and once I did something to get my heart
rate up yeah it would come out lay right
between my collar bones it would just
come up like I had a little lump my lump
my little baby hump that little hump on
my [__] neck I could have put like a
happy face oh and it was starting to
scare the [__] out of me I know and I
had a couple people touch it and they're
like listen just go down there you have
insurance what do you give a [__] yeah
yeah I hear you down there it got popped
out
the
I'm really [__] happy I did it you
know when you go down to the doctor like
you said everything is cancer yep I went
a couple weeks ago I had to do the the
scan from my brain to do the nose
surgery oh yeah like we look for all
this [__] that's what I need to come in
for a nose [__] injection and next
you know I got brain [__] cancer I
didn't know about it yeah all that [__]
especially when you smoke Reef yeah
never [__] mind when you smoke Reef
or do a drug that sets off paranoia in
your mind wow it just sets off yeah I
had dental work done and I was convinced
that my whole jaw had shifted
I took three or four stars and I was I
just got too high yeah I was like my
whole jaw shifted they messed up you
know what I was doing to the guy Jerry
he goes
he's feeling on my neck and here from
there and I go I I don't know dude
because I was online and he's like dude
it's a [__] pulled muscle he said I
know I'm a doctor you're but you're just
like he's got to be wrong it can't just
be a pulled muscle but as you get older
pulled muscles he's all you got
basically a brutal Charlie horse in your
neck so imagine you know like when you
try to run with a charlie horse you
can't run it's the same thing same
[__] thing he goes you got it in your
neck and I was like as soon as they tell
you that also you're like oh cool you
just leave like all right Charlie Horse
it's so weird what the public
perceives as a singer yeah you know
and to be a singer and longevity of a
singer it takes so much [__] work I
read something one and all the great
voices listen uh Robert Plant is not the
same Robert Plant we had 30 years ago I
mean his voice became something else Rod
Stewart is hit and miss Ozzy Osbourne I
don't know what the [__] to think
anymore
but a voice is like a back you never
know when it's gonna go
and the care that goes into a voice like
when you talk to a real singer like a
guy that like Halford Alfred for example
still sounds great I don't know I
haven't seen him live I don't know if he
still sounds like the 81 Alpha he
crushed it so I'm like eight months ago
and like we just think they go off on
stage like right now Sabbath is on tour
and because of their age they do a show
and they take a show off yeah they do a
show you know in the 80s if you went to
a concert in the 70s and the 60s these
guys did four or five nights a week
nobody knew about taking care of your
throat you had witch Tails which is that
what they call like you know gargle with
swords yeah oh yeah which yeah which you
know stories about the road old school
remedies but when you find the real
singer who takes care of themselves like
really like no smoking know this you
know they really put a scarf around
their neck you don't know how much work
goes into being a [__] singer you
know when you do Coke it destroys your
throat completely
destroys your throat you hear it as
you're talking do two lines of coke
that's sitting purple they'll come to
you after a few years and go and knowing
you're in Coke because your voice
changes totally what happens to it it
changes you get a dread a couple lines
and it numbs your voice numbs your vocal
cords so all those dudes that did tons
of blow while they sang supposedly
that's that's why I'll tell you what
I'll tell you who had a great voice
I never saw him when he had a great
voice by the time I got to see him his
voice was shot over the years he's
brought it back and that's Chris Cornell
oh yeah not the [__] slaves and
bulldozers back no but it's he keeps it
at a moderate level then you learn the
tricks totally then you learn the
singers tricks how to do smaller places
you change the songs around to a lower
voice well does it just start going or
is it is it can it just go can you just
wake up one day not have a voice anymore
it can completely go if you don't um
warm up you gotta warm up and as I went
to the vocal uh doctor a couple days ago
I've been singing like all my life you
got to warm up if you don't warm up it's
exactly like going and playing football
in the NFL you're gonna pull stuff and
[__] and what happens is it just gets
shot and tired you know and and even
with podcasting and doing comedy we're
talking for hours and hours and hours
which is uh you know when you're in
regular job or whatever you've just
talked to your co-worker like yeah I was
at a party and then you're working and
you talk but we're talking for hours you
know and and then imagine singing for a
couple hours then you're fired up you
get off stage and you're on the tour bus
talking talk talk talk talk you got AC
going it's drying out your voice and uh
and then you're not getting proper sleep
you're eating like [__] and next thing
you know you add alcohol oh it dries out
your voice boost to the [__] contact
to see it's tough enough doing that [__]
once you add the alcohol and the booze
and the bad food and the No Sleep Jesus
[__] Christ over that's it it's over
and that's basically the life you have
to lead yeah that's basically let's go
in 2000 four and three when I went let's
just say to Houston
I got to Houston on a Tuesday
okay the week started on Wednesday
through Sunday
you did all [__] one two four six
seven seven or eight shows you know
that's eight hours I ate like [__] yep
you know I didn't sleep because I did
blow out of the seven nights I did blow
five nights so my sleeping was
uninterrupted you know that takes a toll
you know talking to people not sleeping
eating greasy food not doing vitamins
not only even breaking the sweat the
only time I would break a sweat in those
days when I was snorting coke it was
like new poke New Coke was pushing out
the old Coke I had new Coke pushing out
the [__] old Coke opening up the
pores yeah you really can't uh
eventually you get sick yeah another
thing exactly man another thing that
people do wrong and they never know this
but you know when you hear people
clearing their throat all the time where
they're going yeah that's the worst
thing you can do for your voice because
it bangs the vocal cords together and as
you keep doing that the banging together
creates like a callus which is known as
a vocal node and that thing gets rock
hard and then you can't sing anymore so
these guys are constantly clearing their
throat it's just going bang bang that's
why a lot of singers drinking tea
they're using uh ricolas and stuff to
keep their voice you know lubed so
whenever I feel something weird in my
throat instead of doing that I would
just drink some water or something and
it'd be you know you're fine but every
time you clear your throat you're
banging the vocal cords together and
it's the worst thing you can do it's
crazy you know it's great to talk to
somebody I love music but I'm not a
musician right so I really don't know I
can't have any justification any level
the should I talk about music when I
talk to you it's so weird the other day
I spoke to you
and I got off the phone with you and I
was so happy to talk to you the other
morning because
I live vicariously through you yeah
I was telling my friend last week I had
to like break it down to him I go avails
his name is a villain I know Bill's
listening and my brother
and I love you to death let me tell you
what's going on with me what's going on
with me is
I love concerts and I love music I never
stopped loving music it was the constant
experience yeah that got on my nerves
for a while you know what I'm saying the
last few concerts I went to I see where
it became money oriented it's like I
tell people now today I love doing
stand-up but this part of stand up I
[__] can't stand yeah I can't stand
going through a town and having to count
chairs and oh you know selling sheath
seats and I hate all that [__] I just
want to do comedy and 98 of bands that
get into it at the end of the day
they'll tell you listen
I don't give a [__] if I live in a
basement under a basement and never have
any money I just want to play music just
that high I would sacrifice all that
family
401k to just play live music that's the
same thing that happens use a comic it
or you know you you do it one day and
you're like you know what I'm quitting
my day job and people like well how are
you going to live how are you going to
pay lee rent yeah you know we'll figure
it out it's 4 10 a month yeah that's a
hundred and two fifty that's a hundred
and two dollars and fifty cents a week I
find that out I'll find it on the street
I could sneeze that [__] yeah right you
could sneeze that [__] it's it's it's
really crazy how you I was on a light
today
and I was like wow you know
I never knew
that I would do what I'm doing with
comedy today like I never knew
I never really knew yeah I was like who
the [__] was I
that's why I made the moves I made
because you had that certain confidence
to jump into it but anyway with all that
[__] I was thinking about you told me
your itinerary for the week yeah and you
were talking about you were gonna go see
this band you were going to see the who
you're trying to scout tickets do I know
anybody who's got a ticket connection
for the who you want to see somebody
else and it's like I live through you
vicariously I have two friends that are
musicians three of them one guy still
goes to shows he's a great musical guy
but when he goes to his show he thinks
about it too much yeah and it drives me
crazy but I can't lie to you I have the
same thing yeah you know what I'm saying
when I go to a show I go to be critical
you know like half of me is critic like
if the singer first couple of times I
went to a show a live show was Ted
Nugent Aerosmith Frank Marino oh yeah
and I went to see something else
and I remember that both times are left
upset even when I went to see the stones
the first time with Foreigner Foreigner
was Exquisite yeah Foreigner did the
songs how they were playing on the album
so far in it did everything to the T
when I went to see the stones they were
completely different than what they were
doing there were some songs like uh you
know that ballads like uh beast of
burden and [__] like that that would to
the money a couple little off takes but
shattered and a couple other songs were
completely different than that when I
was used to I didn't like that too fast
yeah the only bands I liked that did
that was Led Zeppelin right yeah The
Song Remains the Same they took those
songs they switched them around and if
you you're like what the [__] is this
but I the reason we're talking about
singers is because sometimes you hear a
band on your album and you go see the
singer live and you're like oh my
[__] god this is God awful yeah yeah
this is God awful they had a lot of
Studio [__] in his [__] voice you
know yeah well I mean you you spoke
about uh last week I forget the name of
the awards but Britney Spears lip
syncing yeah what would you prefer as a
fan go to a show and see someone lip
syncing or go and see someone who just
came camps oh I want it horrible if it's
going to be horrible I don't want fake
you know that's why I'm there to see
live I'm there to see a live concert and
it's a it's a lot like uh like racing or
uh you know Motocross or something it's
either going to be spectacular it's
going to be a crash you know but that
but that's the live feeling of like oh
my God I saw those guys in the third
song the guitar player was just wasted
you know whatever it is back in the day
now it's it's it's business now it's
business the reason why I was so mad
last week watching that League
was because a I took time out of my day
to watch that [__] and it smacked me in
the face and number two and my man Hill
oh I saw a priest the more than anybody
growing up like I went to see him a lot
like out of all the other bands I saw DC
three or four times but priests for some
reason we always ended up going yep
and out of all those times I went to see
him and he won 82 and he sang solar
Angels oh I love it and he sang it from
the side yeah
and he sang it from the side and I was
real close to him and believe it or not
I could hear the energy from his voice
yeah I could hear the the last flowing
particles of his energy and from his
voice and I was blown away
so at the Palladium which at that time I
don't know what the [__] it said let's
pretend it's that 800 people small venue
then I saw him
I think at the middle hands and he
pretty much did the same thing it
reverbited whatever the [__] the smart
people use you know Echoes and [__] yeah
my point being Britney Spears has had a
show in Las Vegas for the last how many
years yeah like three years three years
just signed another contract okay Janet
Jackson I went to see a music thing one
time and at the University of Denver
some guy a choreographer spoke about
touring and what happens when high
profile acts that move around the lot
Madonna yeah Janet Jackson when you
start the tour before the tour starts
you have six weeks of rehearsal and
everybody comes in like a fat [__] yeah
everybody comes in out of shade few
people come in in shape everybody comes
in out of shape and you start doing the
songs and learning the dance rehearsals
and everybody's huffing and puffing but
throughout that you're gaining cardio so
at the beginning of the tour at
beginning of a Janet Jackson tour it's
noted that 75 percent of the music on
stage is lipstick either music backed or
the singer enhancing her voice on stage
by the end of the tour she's doing 90 on
her own right she's caught up with the
cardio the air is there the whole thing
Britney Spears has been in Las Vegas for
three years doing the same stupid
[__] songs yeah you mean to tell me
she's still lip syncing after all this
[__] time that's what I think about
when I watch that music that all the
[__] money she makes she still
[__] lip syncing and don't tell me
Justin Bieber was a lip sync and [__]
either okay yeah you know the chubby
chick on the [__] thing you know God
bless her uh oh Adele pink a pink pink
God bless her that's another one who
can't sing yeah a duck can't sing yeah a
duck can't sing live she's like Conor
McGregor the Secret's getting out yeah
she can't sing [__] line yeah I
haven't seen her I saw it and she blamed
it on the microphone this and this and
then I put on 19 whatever yeah this The
Allman Brothers live from whatever and
I've seen it if anybody if any of them
microphones fell into the piano yeah and
if anybody claimed responsibility after
the show because that's the world I come
from yeah you know she went out there
[__] the tools were breaking cats
were jumping out windows and [__] glass
was breaking yeah and she's blaming on
the [__] microphone yeah okay now I
know she sings great in studio but if
I'm gonna go pay a deuce to go see this
milkshake [__] yeah I better [__]
you know she's an opera singer belt it
out you fat [__] yeah she got Tommy the
next day she dropped the [__]
microphone in the [__] piano what do
I give a [__] you think Greg Allman ever
did that you did [__] Robin plant
ever woke up and called The Daily News
and said I dropped the microphone the
[__] piano you heard what you heard
because it was real it's a different
world you know it's just so weird
because also now they have the most
state-of-the-art gear they got like
in-ear monitors and oh they only have to
sing like you know I've been chasing
pavement like that whoa you know but
when our gods they had they were
battling [__] Jimmy Page's five
Marshall amps shitty sounding by the way
did you see that video of the drama
takes
John Bonham's drum outtakes from into
the outdoor oh man I almost called you
but it was two in the morning oh
to hear that man play the drums yeah I
always
I don't get insulted but I look at
people weird when they make accusations
against Led Zeppelin oh it's crazy I
mean people have the YouTube videos and
you listen to the YouTube videos and
they're right there in front of you you
know the accusations are right there in
front of you you know Carlos been seeing
years ago used to say I don't steal
jokes I just make them better yeah and
some people laugh I think Led Zeppelin
thought that in their mind sometimes but
as musicians John Paul Jones was a
monster I mean a [__] monster guys in
that Prince level uh yeah right here
look at this it's it's not artistic I
just want you to hear the thunder and
yeah look at it look how cool he looks
first of all look at that [__] man
right here we go you ready he is going
deep on mushrooms right now lays on
mushrooms killer I did some they haven't
affected me like they did yeah it stops
moving uh it stops moving I love it
yeah
crank this lead
[Music]
I'm [__] believable just just Groove
Groove
[Music]
that's the sound of Lee's heart rate
right there
[Music]
so cool man 1979
I said leave before I gotta [__] my head
explodes
that [__] is insane
that's insane how good of a [__]
drama this guy was and people still talk
[__] I think he squashes a lot of people
but it's just his track that's just it's
just him and rehearsing warming up to
rehearse what happened with the Hooters
and I'm going this way okay here's what
I did last week on Tuesday I saw the
Cure at the Hollywood Bowl how were they
fifth row
they played 33 songs and this [__]
guy sang every one of them are you
saying fire Flawless dude I mean you
know just coming out uh love guts you
know just there he is like 63 or
whatever he is just killing it man uh I
mean the you know the two they have so
many [__] hits even if the Cure is
not your flavor you cannot deny the
songwriting man that there was so many
[__] hits then the next night
I go to see the who it was uh me Bittle
comb and uh Spicer Coast on my podcast
Kristen Spicer we go to the Staples I
get uh some free tickets
we got these cool like up high seats
right by the stage where you can just
sit down and like a movie and look down
they open with who are you and it was
unbelievable and after the first song uh
Townsend goes I just want to let you
guys know that this is going to be a
greatest hit show we're gonna play 23
hits and they played 23 [__] hits man
you forget them all I Can See For Miles
oh I forgot about that I could see four
miles yeah Tommy yeah top they played
they played Pinball Wizard they played
mama has a Squeeze Box they played
[__] um quadrophilia my uh my
generation the real me no they did not
yeah the real man rain on me yeah that's
too much Eminence Front oh I love that
one even though it's 82. so I [__]
love Eminence I love that [__] so that's
the tour I went this season me too I
almost went to see him in 76 with who
are you almost yeah I was a little on
the young side and then I'm not gonna
lie to nobody at that time I was still
stuck on Zeppelin and and the who came
to town in New York lit up and all my
friends went to see The Who and we were
gonna go over and I said you know what
I'm gonna stay down the hill and suck
somebody's dead nah I'm not gonna go see
the [__] who and I always regretted
it I was like Keith Moon one and then I
went to see him again with Kenny Jones
Kenny Jones and uh
not the Go-Go's but it was uh The Clash
The Clash Open The Clash opened and
Dexter Point Dexter was the [__] uh
who was from the New York Dolls
what the [__] he was and he opened David
Johansen David Johansen we went out to
uh Long Island and we had a good time I
had T-Bone Burnett The Clash and the who
Oakland Coliseum where the A's play it
was the first farewell tour 82. that was
a farewell tour yep it's hilarious
because I tweeted I tweeted last week in
82 I Saw The Who on their farewell tour
and Wednesday I'm seeing them again so I
guess they were just kidding back then
you know it's like come on but that tour
was great man Kenny Jones on drums from
the faces and of course A lot of people
are like oh no Keith Moon but man they
lit it up they lit it up on that
farewell 82 tour and The Clash crushed
it it was combat Rock Tour you know Rock
the Casbah yeah [__] today is in 1983
was the S Festival yes I went to that
and today is the anniversary of the
metal day uh how many years ago 83. so
um day one The Clash headlined I went
day two Van Halen headlined and day
three David Bowie headline now for
people don't know this was my
generation's Woodstock that's funny it
was in May of 83.
um I mean some [__] missing persons
yeah to stray cats great cats Men at
Work I mean it was just three [__]
days I'm living in Aspen Colorado I'm
watching it on MTV oh yeah yeah MTV
broadcasted it this is what MTV was
really cool they didn't have black kids
knocking up White Chicks crying
throughout the whole [__] show about
what's gonna happen to Leroy I don't
[__] know but he ain't coming back no
jerseys yeah no jerseys it was Jersey
this was when it was uh MTV 83 you know
it was great Lee's a young man but and
Lee your head's gonna explode
Lee can't even think about this like
this conversations I have really
especially tonight with the mushrooms I
still remember
senior year in high school
going to meet my friends to talk about
MTV yeah what just happened well it
wasn't as big I think it was probably on
its way up but when I was in elementary
school we I used to go home because TRL
was on I'm sure that was the dying
divorce not even on not even thinking
about it yeah yeah not even thinking
about it yeah Tiara was never even a
thought in those days at the top of
every hour it was either Nina Blackwood
the black chick
uh the white dude with the [__] Mark
Goodman Mark Goodman the black dude I'm
sorry not a black chick oh yeah yeah
black dude who died yeah the young Irish
JJ JJ whatever yep and they each had
ships now in those days you were just
starting to party starting to do blow
you come home at three in the morning
listen
you can have a conversation and at the
top of the hour you ran to the TV to see
what video was going to come up yeah put
on Pat Benatar
now Hit Me With Your Best Shot no
who's gonna run oh yeah you better run
yeah
I would sit there after school yeah
enter enter
the time she had two videos that were
rocking Lee wake up [__] sucker Lee's on
it Lee's on it we had she had what
you're gonna do to my heart whatever the
[__] that was uh and she had a song
called
you had Hit Me With Your Best Shot
Helen's gonna follow you I'm gonna
follow you yeah put on we gotta put on
Pat Benatar I'm gonna follow you Lee
this is a very obscure video first of
all a lot of people don't even remember
Pat Benatar Pat Benatar 10 albums is she
sick no I said she's so great at that
time guys do you want to watch the video
yeah yeah Pat Benatar uh I'm gonna
follow you at that time there was a
fusion going on these bands that you
didn't expect had these tremendous
guitarists that with cutting line of
heavy metal guitar whether it was Billy
Idol was it was cutting line uh Jake
Jake what's his name no you got Steve
Steve
yeah
hit it yeah but this is her husband on
guitar this is her second album yeah
this album [__] blew up
listen to the guitar on this yeah
Crimes of Passion great record great
[__] album great record look at her
too
I would stay up all night waiting for
this [__] video guys oh I'm not gonna
lie to anybody
I do I do what yeah
super hot
just 80s hot right there oh
it's funny because right now she looks
like a school teacher you know
it's a long hash you got streaks yeah
yeah she still does the hot not the
Hollywood Bowl but the other one every
year oh the Greek The Canyon Club oh the
can cook oh yeah like this time August
she does it and I'm always out of town
yeah her husband on guitar
Neil Geraldo
when I saw him I went to Pat Benatar as
a goof let's get this out of the way at
the time let this go Lee let this go I
want you to hear the guitar solo Oh Yeah
at the time I was going anything I went
to see the police with some raggy band
of course I've gone to see ya
that was in the city
and I was I date this girl I liked her
we were talking
a buddy of mine called me that night in
the Meadowlands I said I'll go with you
and I went to see Pat Benatar and at
that time
it was the top three concert sciency and
I had seen everybody at that time wow
they would just she was bad kickily
watch the guitar
crank this openly
their house for children I love it on
live oh
I don't know if you remember 1983 and 84
she got an HBO special here we go into
this guitar kick it Lee kick this
Soldier Lee
oh [__]
I'm telling you [__] you guys
don't know about patent [__] Neil put
on you better run watch this
[__] yeah Lisa we go home and
put on MTV in those days it was this
fish heads mighty mighty fish heads
sticks yeah sticks six oh now there was
another channel that was on board way
before MTV it came on after it was USA's
nightlife oh yeah Night Flight night
flight yeah remember that they showcased
the star they did this they did that
and uh that was pretty cool but this
nothing was like MTV 24 7. we would
snort coke look at Neil hamburger look
at this look why yeah headed Leaf in the
beginning yeah
you're slipping Lee where's the sandwich
it's coming okay you're slipping here
those mushrooms again look at them yeah
look at her yeah busted it super hot
1981 guys [__] busted it
look at spandex hot
look at it I didn't even have big
titties you didn't need them I didn't
need them women were [__] women they
were Savages yeah look at this dirty
[__] go Pat yeah
oh yeah man
see the guitar lurking the whole [__]
time yeah
Neil rocks
all right leave speed it up a little bit
we're gonna [__] right there with a
line right right there go ahead
[Music]
here we go watch this [__] Lee your
head's gonna [__] blow up put the
speakers on easily boom here we go Lee
watch her little skinny ass wiggle watch
this
that's a hit hit song right there
wow
look at this guitar guys just take
[__] notes Here we go and look at
this skinny look at this Savage yeah oh
[__]
yeah Lee check the Sabbath don't take
guys off the big screen
take a look don't take the Isley hit it
hit it oh screaming oh [__]
Stratocaster
[Music]
[__] yeah
look at this Savage
whoa
wow wow
[Music]
oh [__] here we go right here
are you [__] nuts
um
Benatar promo 1983 HBO wow yeah HBO
special twice she's an HBO on catch a
rising stars 20-year anniversary she
started there really during the open
mics in the 70s so she became uh she's
just going down and singing like covers
and stuff wow you never even knew that
so prep who do you think you're dealing
with here play by the time you know
what's funny HBO special after this then
you get the spin-offs like quarter flash
yes that's a great great bag I saw him
for Sammy Hagar I [__] loved
quarterflation what are we doing here
Pat Benatar HBO promo
you over there
stuttering and [__] yes
there you go hit it let's see what we
got right there uh concert 83. look at
that wow you think you're dealing with
guys yeah look at this look at her guy
look at it with her little gloves wow
there's no sound they took the sound out
what yeah HBO's [__] greedy bastards
wow that thing that's cool I never even
knew something yes HBO right there
there's one oh that's the MP3 of it
crazy he knows this [__] I'm trying to
drop it on you [__] Now look
for Pat Benatar catch a rising star oh
yeah let's see what you got there let's
see that there you go oh there you go
watch this [__] there it is there you go
it may not be her oh the 10th
anniversary IMDb then keep scrolling
keep scrolling keep scrolling down down
down to the flounder
let's see if that's it no
promises in the dark gray one jacket
crackily cranky promises in the dark
right there crackly [__] tremendous a
[__] Savage yeah I went to see her
right there there you go right there oh
yeah you want the rehearsal one now
let's just check that one yeah let's
look at the rehearsal see if it's uh
cool like uh it's the video from the
video so this is what it is it's the
yeah oh this is cool oh look at her
outfit
straight Flashdance era the outfit
[Music]
okay so you have crimes of passion and
then promises are that this album is
called something different this album is
called
precious [__] time yeah another
guitar solo that's
[__] tremendous
this girl is hot
now she's lip syncing
on the video on the video but not live
[Music]
crank this mule League we ain't [__]
around tonight yeah one other mushroom
are you ready to go demons with murky
Waters
you ain't even seen nothing yet here's a
big build up I love it here we go Lee
kick it
[Music]
look at him with his [__] ponies on
and [__] yeah
the PC Rich guitar look at him I'm
telling you guys he was a Savage
yeah
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me awesome
get off
[Music]
I grew up on this [__] dog I didn't give
a [__]
[Music]
drummer's killer Myron Rob Becker was
his name
[Music]
are you oh I gotta smoke some weeds
this [__] BC Rich
[Music]
are you nuts
so good
but talk is cheap
watch this guitar boys and girls
[Music]
damn it here you go
oh [__] hey this is a killer guitar solo
[Music]
away from another mushroom Lee we're
taking a deep it's Memorial Day soldiers
died for you [__] and don't call
Van Khan and Africa and you're sitting
there headedly kick this mule
[Music]
are you [__] nuts I love that one
people take notes I'm not we're not
dropping this on you yeah so you can sit
there like a [__] move yeah
[Music]
what a [__] solo
that guy's underrated man oh I always
knew he was a bad [__]
[Music]
this rock
just when you think
[Music]
oh
they whisper
here we go
[Music]
foreign
all right here you go uh
the sister song for this album was
[Music]
Pat better talk something about ice
Fire and Ice go ahead it's Fire and Ice
and we'll speed through just the guitar
solos we're going to give you an
education if I remember this I'm gonna
go to another guy that I found the
island at a live tape of him that I
nearly died how good he was oh who's
that like a Tom playing the little guy
from the Cars oh God Elliot Easton
Easton dude that [__] let's just
call him Isis oh my God that guy killed
let's call him Isis he's just that great
he's just that [__] great oh in this
tape I found I almost had to go shoot my
I'm like that's Isis right there oh he
swear I'm listen it's a song off of
Candy-O yeah I don't know what I a song
I watch but we'll find it so we're
looking for Pat Benatar Fire and it's
very nice I'm a [__] fan but I gotta
tell you once love in the battlefield
come out yeah it was just a matter of
time before some bloody shot that was
the rehearsal that would blew me away
watch this this is the sister she did
both these videos on the same night it
was the same outfit right right it just
changed for yeah
here we go here we go
oh yeah yeah
I'm telling you guys I wouldn't be
[__] shoving this down your throat
these two albums [__] great man just
right up there with heart
oh yeah
oh
look at that outfit
one piece cat suit
Jesus Christ
oh great songs
[Music]
we used to shove this song Down
gorilla's next and they go coach we came
over here let's be Iron Maiden yeah yeah
you got this on listen this is it you
gotta hear this [__] to me back then it
was yes
right I would put this on the Michael
shankman you know then Black Sabbath
there was nothing you know quarter flash
yeah
oh man that saxophone oh yeah yeah
quarter flask song I'll tell you who
else
I'm gonna tell you who else it's a
Powerhouse man that normally ever
function yeah
they you spit people don't even know and
women if you're gonna get into music if
you ain't down with the [__]
Pretenders oh Chrissy Hinds take some
lessons check oh wait we got Pretenders
one two oh yeah oh you think about this
[__] you know like what what was going
on what's what all right take Italy
watch this guitar right here we go here
we go
thank you
down
another shredley kick this mirror
oh
you guys oh
foreign
just the guitar again guys you gotta
this is listen everybody knows about Abe
Lincoln and George Washington oh if you
want to run with the big boys you
dropped this [__] song at a party and
they'll look at you they'll say where
the [__] did you come home you [__]
gave you this where did you find this
[__] yeah it's like what what is this
[__] you know what I mean it's
incredible like how great the songs are
you know like she's this chick's got
like seven [__] hits eight hits I'll
tell you what at that time everybody was
putting out good hours yeah the quality
of the albums were very high when Pat
Benatar released crimes of passion I
didn't tell you this how it is not the
live performance the regular one when
Pat Benatar released crimes of passion
that was one of the first albums so that
I can look right there look at the album
cover that's the album cover yep
okay Harry with a little shoot looking
to the floor the album before this was
like into the night or something it had
uh show me a lover and something else
when what were we talking about here
these mushrooms are hitting me too we're
talking about [__] hell how great the
guitar is you know you had her you
the song she had I think
there's so many times I got coked up and
just looked at this album cover yeah
this was a dark tune for the times this
is crazy you know [__] Luca came
years later with my name is Luca yeah I
live on the second floor this took you
to the
are you [__] kidding me so God
Crank that way I want you to blow the
speakers out for me I want these people
to go what the [__] is Joey doing yeah
love and pain become one and the same in
the eyes of the Wounded child are you
[__] kidding me
yeah love and pain become the same are
you [__] kidding me people don't know
nothing about that yeah
this is the last song on the album on
that side
it leads into this guys it's a [__]
masterpiece
bound or down now I down down Whatley
eat another mushroom way out of respect
for Patty B
itch
it's also confusing
Jesus
oh
tell Grandma you fell off the swing just
get lyrically yeah Masterpiece a [__]
Masterpiece ladies and gentlemen and
look how the temples build them up
are you
listen if you got the syringe just stick
it in your [__] eyeball right now end
this time you listen to bat better
thought that was for children
here we go kick the sleep
there's no [__] idea ladies and
gentlemen to see this live
it sounded just like this
and Neil Geraldo swag this [__]
thank you
[Music]
oh are you [__] pretty like no
[__] Parolees
[Music]
give me some elite air guitars
apparently listen to this monster
oh shitley
[Music]
yeah
he just jumped on that horse ladies and
gentlemen he ain't coming to listen he
still ain't getting off
it's like Joe Perry and [__]
73. he ain't getting off the horse
listen
ing
[Music]
goalie you [__]
we're eating the whole Bagley tonight
that's it we're going to the hospital
[Music]
are you [__] kid and then thank you
good night and you guys like Joey you
know you're gay what the [__] no this
was you know you had to be diverse and
this was what you know I like Sade yeah
an 85 when [__] Shante hit the thing
operator that those first two hours
those first two shot damn the [__]
monsters this is No Ordinary Love oh man
all that we were talking about uh
uh what was that
Quarterflash oh yeah Quarterflash they
had they had a big hit they had two big
hit right one or two yeah they had two
big hits
Lee you're [__] up the money
I had uh yeah
caught a flash yeah kill you
all right yeah Court of Flesh f-l-a-s-h
I saw him open for Sammy Hagar on the
standing Hampton tour they're on you
know what if you listen to like 80s I
made or if you listen to like uh
anything on Sirius these guys come on
once a [__] week hard in my heart
find another fool also
we're hard in my heart it's the big big
hit but look at it straight up the
formula it's just like record company
like okay we're gonna go with a Pat
Benatar here 82. yeah this is 82 towards
the end but she didn't get close no this
is also on HBO yeah yeah we grew up on
this on TV I'm sorry yeah MTV big time
this video was all over the place
back when videos mattered
oh yeah
this video used I remember being at a
New Year's party yeah 81 and seeing this
[__] video and going you can't jerk
off to this lady with the [__]
straight black I mean you know yeah
[Music]
total Hall and Oates flavor
yeah he's peeking over here
lay on the controls
[Music]
then they had another chick Lee Preston
Scandal oh yeah Scandal what was that
jam they did I like that second album uh
yeah Scandal had a big hit it's funny
that they opened for Sammy Hagar you
know like and she was like a school
teacher
[__] got a hit song I'll send her out
on tour Scandal Scandal the Heat of the
Night that's something
there it is what is it uh you had it
there for a minute yeah yeah
uh
heavy as the head let's see what that
one is no that's not it no that's not it
um
Scandal what's the Scandal yeah that was
the band Scandal I remember hold on hold
on the name the the one
Scandal what was their song oh
put Scandal band Scandal yeah yeah
that's it
there we go
Okay so
no no no not goodbye to you goodbye to
you oh yeah remember that one goodbye to
you goodbye to you really good song was
not the warrior oh yeah I am the warrior
that was a great warrior but Love's
gotta lie on you beat of the heart is
that oh yeah B to the heart that's the
jam put on Beat of the heart yeah watch
this little [__] Jam
there it is p to the heart let's see
this is the gym I'm just [__] talking
is it
oh [__] yeah
okay yeah
there's all these Pat benatars all of
them then that chick I don't wanna fall
in love oh y'all wanna suck your dick
with the [__] ponytails
I had a little too much today look at
this girl huh yeah
because this Jam was good
super 80s I love it
it's funny because the 80s had all these
different flavors but they were all 80s
like you had stray cats and minute work
and all that that's 80s this is 80s and
I am a warrior super 80s
put on
[Music]
oh [__] to Pretenders oh yeah oh yeah
put on The Pretenders oh [__] one
okay you know this was another like if
you Pat Benatar and you know Patty Smite
were completely different totally but
then this chick showed up with this band
called The Pretenders and one night when
I was really young I was still living at
the Benders I had this guy squeaks ID
one of the guys from the neighborhood
said hey you want to go see this band
and pretend this and I was like I don't
even know who the [__] the pretenders
are they took me to some [__] like a
mid-level I don't know the name of it in
New York God The Pretenders Pretend This
debut full album vinyl that right there
yeah that one okay this is a [__]
band with a chick well she's so outlawed
look at her look at that ass oh God yeah
listen for this [__] oh yeah come on
this is this way edgy
oh oh I went to see these [__]
and this drama
was hitting the drum and making the
drumstick go at you in the audience
[Music]
precious
precious I forgot all about this this
[__] is the bomb
This Record
yeah Make Me Wanna
fast forward this lead this album's got
this is the debut album all right it's
all hits and it probably had Keith
basketball when I got it leave right
there bam fast forward
[Music]
[Applause]
a little more
when I've been here oh yeah Jesus Christ
I I got into these guys and I lived in
Aspen Colorado oh in my little bedroom I
ended up one time like I got it I went
to see them keep fast falling we keep
fast forward there's a good Jam coming
up right here
a little more a little more big
a little more
[__] jackets a little more you know
the jacket's [__] up Jack it's
amazing here we go uh private live brass
in the pocket yeah brass in the pocket
Pockets big [__] [__] side two so go to
keep going Lee keep going right there
start this in the beginning listen to
this [__] guys that's great this is it a
little more
oh right there
crank this [__] shut up listen guys
this if you never got into the
Botanicals pretend there's one and two
and there's a song on two every time I
put it on my tear falls out of my eye oh
what one
I bought you letters you my friend so
many letters I never said listen for
this [__] crank this [__] horse sleep
oh my God this [__] is the bomb oh my
[__] god
[Music]
oh Chrissy Hine
wow
oh
oh man
I opened up my mouth what was it it's
that jam yeah this is the one
time for dinner Jesus Christ so good I
need it since I had this out mine
this album has a longer running time
than most average LPS
to cheat for Effective play Loud
[Music]
you show me what that hole was
right here
oh I love her
she's got a brick out came out last year
total gangster she married Davies one of
the Davies yeah yeah yeah she's been
married 18 times yeah but let me tell
you how I know
that Karen Dean Delray are the real deal
August 14th
1984. yeah she was Touring that album
that came out December of 93. oh yeah
Romano D's writer kills himself what's
the [__] arm that came out in 83 Lee
not done with mirrors that's Aerosmith
right there right uh no right there
right there learning
put that on Lee there's a jam I used to
listen to it was you know December of 83
I had no [__] family yeah I was
living in a great little condo oh the
road this is no [__]
believe you gotta find the song guys
keep going sometimes they put the songs
in it which one do you want
like in the description let's look at
the uh show more there we go
I'm back on the Chain Gang man she does
a thin line between love and Harry
Potter that is tremendous but on 2 000
months two thousand miles faster yeah it
was the [__] holidays oh I was by
myself yeah no girlfriend I was a thief
I was a burglar I was making a ton of
money though yep I would snort coke
three four nights a week and whack off
and I almost got to suck the neighbor's
titties upstairs and [__] well Robin and
stealing but December of 83 This is the
song I would listen to and I get [__]
heartbroken every time this song came on
sounds like Christmas great you got dust
right
this is verify are you [__] nuts I'm
bringing back deep [__] tonight it's a
great record this is the [__] I used to
listen to when I was on the [__] run
man this chick is killer
foreign
[Music]
Jerry there's a song she does you gotta
hear it bad boys get spanked oh please
bad boys
that's the second album that that song
is so good her second album guys like
most women most bands have a you know
because they have lived all their life
to put out the first album the second
album sucks from The Pretenders was a
[__]
bad boys get spanked Pretenders oh there
you go right there oh my God this
[__] song this is Pretenders too I'm
not telling you this is so good
this song crashes look at the look right
there love it look at her [__] jacket
yeah look at this [__] oh this song
oh [__] yeah
[Music]
kick that mule
foreign
[Music]
like
I talked them into it yeah yeah
bad boys get sped oh
yeah
crazy [__] music
this is like a punk rock that's punk
rock because she's from the United
States yeah yeah you're not really
English no from Ohio Ohio
I had uh this is amazing but I had the
bass player for uh Devo Jerry casali on
my podcast and she went to Ohio State
she was there during the shootings and
so was he and he said that she would
always be like why don't you guys let me
sing with you guys and they're like get
out of here and then when Devo toured uh
London their first tour he never saw her
again and she showed up backstage I got
my own band now [__] you guys and it was
Pretenders and they and he said he went
and saw him and I was like Wow [__]
great it was uh I went to see them
August 14th the night before on the pier
she had slipped on stage and broke her
ankle or her leg
and they canceled the Monday night or
something but she went on Tuesday night
and it was uh it was [__] tremendous
she came out limped out with to uh what
do you call those scratches crutches
yeah and there would be applaud and she
took the two crutches she threw him into
the audience oh and the rest was [__]
history she did two [__] hours
Standing Ovation two on cause and I
always respected that I never forgot
that because let's let's face it she had
a broken [__] lick you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah she [__] I saw
her I saw them uh live three times and
every time just crushing same thing with
like the cars like we were talking about
just hit after hit after hit like the
Cure the cars the pretenders put on
dangerous type live oh and watch this
Sean Elliott I don't even know what the
[__] guy's name was like I said
ladies sometimes I'm getting stoned yeah
I'm in the house I'm writing and I got
the computer rolling the computer if you
put one song on it goes on automatic
roll yeah and you just listen to music I
don't care what they play I as long as I
don't have to [__] with it and this song
came up and I had a [__] switch when
I was writing like stuck putting periods
and [__] update chapter yeah and I
went right to this and I probably
watched it two or three times oh here it
is man let's watch The Midnight Special
one killer
Elliot Easton he was left-handed
and uh just a crushing guitar player
oh God he's so great
oh
[Music]
Rico Kasich I finally got to see them on
the third album oh yeah and it was one
of the worst things I ever saw in my
life in Central Park but the sound was
off oh it was outdoor they didn't know
how to [__] contain it yeah you know
yeah
ticketly
[Music]
that's my dog over there look at him
yeah he's a nerdy [__] that walks too
right
[Music]
[__] yeah
oh I love all this [__] guys there's the
Devo I'm just trying to share it with
you [__] been or on base he was
the man Ben Orr sang All the Hits
[Music]
[Applause]
he died right he died yeah somebody died
he released the solo album he was
amazing
maybe
91 maybe 92 90.
[Music]
that guy was the ugliest dude ever and
he married that supermodel Paulina and
they're still married
[Applause]
full of cash because this guy had so
many hits
[Music]
[Applause]
Ben orange remember his song who's going
to drive you home
he sang a couple great songs
he sang something on two that's great
yeah candy is the record
look how dopius
like you
[Music]
what a great [__] band this band 20
so I saw him live on the uh Shake It Up
Tour 20
21 after another they had no piss tracks
I kept going playing shitty song so I
can go pissed no they didn't have one
they didn't have any piss tracks I think
two and one of masterpieces
once they did the one with the third one
yeah I Disappeared that's it I was deep
into something well I always knew they
rocked oh absolutely I bought candy oh I
bought 10 times
[Music]
look at it
murdering it
[Music]
so good dude we love music man sorry if
this is not the music for you tonight or
whatever the [__] I wouldn't push in the
wrong direction now this is the [__] I
got into along with everything else I
got into that was Heavy I mean listen
you can listen to you know Led Zeppelin
so much you've got to put in Fleet with
Mac Rumors oh God you know when I was a
kid like I always told him the Rogan
podcast I do two things I'm not a
judgmental person but I am I judge you
by what you got in your refrigerator and
what albums you got yeah yeah
there's no reason for us to even get
this thing started I said the same thing
all the time you got bad music taste
what are we gonna make this mix yeah
yeah because you must have bad taste on
all kinds of stuff bad judgment you know
it's really weird how you judge people
in that when I was younger oh my God if
I went to your house and you didn't have
listen I don't want you to have sad
Bloody Sabbath but you better have
[__] paranoid yeah yeah I don't want
you to have 22 LEDs up now but you gotta
have one too yeah I don't want you to
have every Santana on but you gotta have
a breakfast you gotta have dark side of
the moon you gotta have deep purple uh
not when we rock we rock this one arm of
this that's [__] tremendously space
we never really talk about them too much
we did you grow up with deep purple fan
you know the truth I I deep purple was
before me but when I went to go see
Sabbath with Ian Gillen singing then I
found him you know what I mean it went
backwards because I saw The Saboteur
born again and that that was one record
with Ian Gillen and I was like this is
this guy's [__] great I knew I knew
uh uh their their standard hits you know
but then later on after I saw a Sabbath
with him and he quit and got Deep Purple
going again I even like the Deep Purple
with uh you know uh perfect strangers
record man that that record was [__]
great uh once he comes back they get
back together
but I love Ian Gillen I think his voice
is so [__] cool and the B3 in uh in
uh Deep Purple the B3 plane it's insane
the Oregon plan
I love it man and I love Rainbow
see I didn't really get once I heard
Smoke on the Water the neighborhood I
grew up with that's all I [__] heard
yeah so right away you you have this
apprehension towards them and then I
bought it down by then and I didn't
think it was any good I didn't really
appreciate that music at the time
sometimes you buy an album and you're
not really ready for it that's right it
takes a different road to get back to
the house and go oh you two are tongue
baby hated it when it came out I was
like I sold it back I was like I don't
want this it's terrible now it's one of
my favorite records of all time really
yeah I I just so it does happen I
thought sometimes you think it's just
you you're like I don't like that I took
mushrooms I went and saw them live and
uh and they played that whole record and
I was like holy [__] I saw God you know
I felt like I saw God they had that the
Mini Coopers flying over me I was I was
just pissing in the crowd there's it was
people rocking like this they didn't
even notice they started pissing in the
crowd I didn't want to lose my good spot
you know and [__] lights are going
I'm like oh [__] you know but I fell in
love with that record and uh it happens
like when I grew up when I was growing
up I hated Springsteen and I hated it
yeah Springsteen
I moved to Boulder yeah and then and
then people walk you down the wrongs the
right steps yeah the worst thing ever is
when you're a young kid
okay you guys have no idea what we're
talking about okay you don't know what
it's like to get a paper route for
example oh shovel snow and all I'm
saying you put all your 695 in you go
buy this album and by your morals it's a
piece of [__] okay let me tell you what
happens you immediately shut down on
that band you shut down because they
took your 6.95 you know how important
yes 6.95 was there dude you could have
bought Led Zeppelin too again you could
have bought so many albums I'll tell you
what band did that to me and I'm sorry
if I insult anybody in your Cheap Trick
oh yeah I put a cheap trick out what one
not Bogota whatever
not happen tonight in color something
that had to happen in 80. yeah it
happened before 480. oh yeah all right
and it was so [__] bad to what I was
listening to it at the time you know I
remember one time I I can't lie nobody
gonna be pissed at me I bought a beach
boys up I thought I was gonna jump out
the window and stab somebody yeah
because it was like a double album yep
and all I wanted was all I got was the
one song like I didn't pick up anything
else same thing happened one time when I
bought a Frankie Valli and a Four
Seasons now that was a bad investment
they had like two good songs and six of
them I didn't know what the [__] I was
talking about I got Frank I got mad at
Frankie Valli for a while didn't like
Sinatra yeah I like two or three songs
growing up now I can at least tolerate
them I get it I get where the [__]
that's coming from so just because
you're turned off to somebody somebody
who I always be turned off so I don't
know why is rush but on the other hand I
love Triumph wow you know laying on the
line is a [__] great Jam fight the
good fight they're banned out of Canada
that that's how I got really introduced
to Canada sometimes you're like who the
[__] is Canada that was me with April
Wine yeah yeah April Wine same [__]
yeah just between you and me oh yeah I
like that
[Laughter]
you're like really dude this song's
touching you
here now you're messing with this
message let me see how that makes white
people act oh nice white guys that goofy
like it's like this it's like when you
see them listening to Thin Lizzy The
Boys Are Back In Town yeah same crew
guys to get they smoke cigarettes
they're the part-timers yeah that's
really weird they just want the head and
I you know what crazy the thing that
bothers me and what a lot of people
don't know this and again I'm sorry if
I'm not dropping the right names
then Lizzie's a badass band yeah but
there's not one station that plays
anything else but like two or three of
that shitty [__] songs yeah we talked
about that before that's right we don't
make you hate it they [__] make you
hate it because they play that [__] down
your [__] throat yeah there's so many
times that you're driving you're like
what the [__] is this I think what I
heard the other day I had a really
[__] good Panther song oh really well
yeah like something that made me go what
the [__] is this you know I like to
discover music when I'm in a car I'm not
sitting there hating on music my fingers
will keep going actually I got Studio
54. oh yeah I got 80s I got the uh the
Seattle Boneyard
and uh
that's all you [__] need on there but
you still keep the other channels open
you listen to The Rock the Elvis I got
the Dead live one oh a deadline one is
very good it really is good [__] yeah
that's for a long drive it really is
when you really want to stay up and you
smoke like a half a doob the dead will
get you there it's like uh it's not a no
dose it's like a can of Coke yeah it's
like a can of Coke yeah the dead is
always I didn't [__] like that that
grown me either hated I hope the bold
and I started dating this girl and she
used to always play working man's dead
and it just sunk into my heart then
there was another album she played the
circle then there was just and then you
know when you live in Boulder
everybody's got bootlegs yeah everybody
comes with bootlegs and bootlegs when
you're studying you listen to a bootleg
and you really
understand where they're coming from
that's that's the beauty about music
sometimes that sometimes you listen to
it sometimes you really get where the
[__] they're coming from when I listen
to Sabbath I know where they're coming
from when I listen to uh
Allman Brothers oh man you know I know
where the [__] they're coming [__] yeah
I had you I got you a poster yeah I got
you an AC DC pool lithograph PostNet
when I was in Pittsburgh there was a
soda Fizz store and they said oh yeah I
got Rogan uh uh lemon skin and yeah the
Rolling Stones and 10cc sick from that
thing in London yeah and I got you AC DC
just a sick lineup of [__] Savages
I'll give it to you I drop I'll put a
mic on take it to the store that's
amazing yeah you get those you look at
those old school lineups and you look at
like Oakland in San Francisco
a thousand uh posters and you look at
the prices and you'll [__] think like
who's making all this money yeah the
doors wanted 10 bucks a ticket yeah you
know in those days and I tell you I seen
Pink Floyd for 15. and it didn't set me
back no two-week salary oh okay that
[__] Us festival I got the ticket
stuff and I instagrammed the photo
twenty dollars
twenty dollars twenty dollars in 1983 to
see 20 bands here's where here's who I
saw for twenty dollars on on the Rock
day it was opening band was Quiet Riot
then the second band was Motley Crew
then you had Ozzy with the first gig
with Jakey Lee then it was Judas Priest
and they had just had screaming for
vengeance out Triumph scorpions with the
blackout out record and then Van Halen
that was twenty dollars
twenty dollars for one day the next day
you know you had David Bowie uh Joe
Walsh
yeah yeah it's just crazy guys it was
crazy and it was in a nice where was it
it was in San Bernardino out in the
desert there where it's a it's a it's a
Amphitheater now I forget what it's
called uh
um it's in Purdue but it's right off the
10 there going to the 15 going to Vegas
now how many days did you stay there I
stayed I went all three days so it
started on Saturday when Saturday Sunday
Monday we left on Friday we drove down
from the Bay Area we had a uh Toyota
Chinook my mom rented it and brought me
and my two buddies and Chinook is like a
a small camper on a Toyota little pickup
driving that thing down we camped there
we took mushrooms and there was no trees
it was like 110 degrees each day no
trees Steve wozinak put it on the guy
who started apple with Steve Jobs
that's who put that card yeah what was
enact man he put that on
it's crazy you know where I was that
weekend where
I was living in Basalt Colorado
where's that the salt Colorado is about
I'm just give or take 20 miles from
Aspen going south on the 82 there right
and I was living in there and I remember
that two of those guys the three of them
I lived with four guys one of them
mothers had died and he went back That's
Mike Duffy yeah that's the kid I sent
money to like six weeks ago he called me
he was having problems and that's how
long I go back with Mike wow I left New
Jersey on April 25th of 1983 and a car
with a [__] Olympic ball going
through the middle and two speakers in
the back the only eight track we had was
Led Zeppelin uh trampled on the foot
album uh Physical Graffiti good one and
we drove from New Jersey to Aspen
Colorado we left Thursday night
at 10 o'clock at night and we got the
Aspen Colorado with five in the [__]
afternoon Saturday afternoon and we went
out and got an eye and whatever then I
ended up the house where these three
guys it was me Jimmy Burkle a guy George
Burkle and Mike Duffy
and then there was a guy in the basement
that they call him the garbage man or
something he was a garbage man
yeah but he went back because something
had happened and Duffy's mom died so I
ended up getting one of the rooms you
know and three of those guys or two of
them had gone to Colorado Springs for
the weekend so I had this huge house in
Basalt Colorado to myself
at the time I had a little bit of weed
but I was smoking like a fiend in those
days
and and he kept telling me George kept
saying listen if you want weed in the
freezer
and his homegrown that'll knock you the
[__] out homegrown in the freezer okay
and he goes we keep it in that it's
deadly and I'm like I looked at my weed
that I had bought an aspen for I don't
know what it was and I looked at the
weed and the freezer guys it looked like
Lauren that you had cut yeah trimming
trimmings yeah and they put in the bag
they had to be guys six ounces in there
yeah yeah okay
guys do you know one day I ran out of
weed now they want to take the bus up
the ass and I said [__] it I've been
smoking good weed all day I'll smoke
this tonight guys
Juno was one of the strongest weeds what
I had ever smoked just the [__] that
[__] leaves about a month later he
came back and he goes Jesus [__]
Christ I told you to smoke a little bit
not the whole bag yeah I had probably
smoked two ounces of that swag the
ugliest weed you ever leave it was grass
cut yeah Lee is giving me the maluk like
I'm not getting the milk at all what's
going on with you least why you give me
the Malu are you high oh my God I'm just
enjoying what are you doing you want
another mushroom I need another cap how
much did Aaliyah take how many cups did
you take did you take a you took one
huge one a gram no I don't know no no he
needs a gram he needs to eat it I never
take more than a gram when I do
mushrooms and then I had the little cap
ready yeah you ready for another one
yeah it's time let's take a look at it
let's see this let's see these [__]
things
this is just satanized these I'm gonna
eat a piece I need another one this is a
good buzzer wearing red healing Lee I'm
gonna eat the little shitty one the
little city where'd you guys buy an
eighth no no no this is from one of my
favorite Jews in the world oh doubt you
know how we do it yeah Lee look at this
for you this is a tiny one wow well
[__] give that to him
eat that up get some more [__] I love
when they're all blue inside that's when
the [__] died that's the psilocybin
Mania that's the [__] that kills the
mule mm-hmm police sciatica lee dog this
is easily
are you ready I'm not ready but oh [__]
why aren't you ready
I'm seeing the devil right now no I can
see the way you're looking at me that
you're knocking on the door yeah Lee
looks normal right now I've seen Lee way
worse
that's probably me I'm sorry oh oh there
I am there I am look at this one and
[__] too my oh [__] that's a little cute
one right there oh [__] but that's the
cutest one of them none of them will
hurt you let me power that up dude
believe these things taste like [__]
ass oh yeah just right now brush my
teeth two times yeah yeah just eating
butthole I just swallow him dog I don't
even oh you do no more yeah you know I
just learn how to swap I like to chew
them because they just so gross but no
no no no no you don't want to do that to
no but that's my boy Lily you take these
next time we'll get what's left and
we'll boil them and we'll make a tea oh
yeah put some sugar in that
[__] some lemon leaves yeah my
buddy used to wrap them in peanut butter
peanut butter around them and then eat
them like that it takes too long to get
high though oh lee you're such a [__]
Trip Lee dog
here you go
little uh
Us festival Rob Halford KK Downing in
the summer they're in the outdoor
weather look the outdoor weather
[__] short-sleeved leather oh my
priests don't [__] around 104 degrees
they wear leather people when does it
[__] end we eat mushrooms we eat
[__] Edibles from the name of the
Lord Lee eat that mushroom come on we
gotta go let's go you should ate it by
now already what the [__] you do
you're sitting there like a mama Luca
here eat it with a cookie uh Red Band
just hit me he's watching wants to know
if you'll do Wednesday night with us in
the main room 8 30.
no I got a podcast that eighth I'm gonna
be at the store tomorrow night though
for the host of Comedy Store though oh
you doing the potluck yeah the potluck
oh damn okay
Lee trust me when you eat this right now
we're knocking on the door very lightly
we eat this last one you right now I
hear that hump the same hum you hear
[Music]
we want the hunt to go away leave the
quicker you do equally the quicker you
go to bed you know what I'm saying yeah
leave man just think you're gonna have
some psychedelic dreams we're gonna pick
up mama tonight you know what I like
about mushrooms when they first come on
does this happen to you your back teeth
start to flow oh my God they start to
float right isn't that crazy my whole
[__] jaw is floating yeah weird
totally but get the water ready Liam now
you're gonna puke hurry up there you go
got that lady
oh look at you bad [__] plug in
his nose eating dirty socks Lee's eating
The Dirty Sock right now just foot mold
water's dripping down his neck this is
ladies and gentlemen this is this is it
we do this [__] for you we go on test
and we don't do it no more we wanted a
[__] hashtag for three weeks oh man
we just do this [__] to let you now
listen everybody put the fear of God
we're just having fun here we're not
doing blow no we're not doing stupid
heroin we're talking about music we're
eating some mushrooms we're getting the
stone to the gills next time I'll Uber
over and we'll smoke the hash okay all
right all right the one night you call
me the other day he said he smuggled
three ounces in his [__] he says wait
till you taste this thing whoa he says
it tastes like [__] but you'll
yo what's up baby boy look at you
becoming a [__] man on a podcast when
you came on here you hadn't done nothing
you were drinking soda yeah you had a
hat with a propeller you know no [__]
you never even had a skateboard you
weren't banging nobody no yeah just an
outlaw look at you an outlaw
a YouTube Warrior podcast [__] every
[__] yeah look at you tougher than
[__] half these guys I just don't
know what to expect it should be fun you
should call Ari and Tom you want to be
the [__] uh whatever and it's
mushroom Fest then you want to hold your
own [__] party
wait till we inhale 10 of these
[__] you don't think that was a
gram that was totally green what I had
wow
no [__] Graham yeah I go I go nothing
over a ground stem tasted so badly oh
just foot I tasted I didn't even bite
into it but I could my throat picked a
little bit of it up just dirt foot I
don't know where I put my nicotine gum
it's not gonna be bouncing off
this [__] I'm popping that nicotine can
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah he loves it he's
back on it oh yeah he pops that nicotine
he does those coffees you got to see him
yeah his glasses get all [__] up yeah
yeah yeah love him man I was hanging
with him last night at the store great
night at the store last night good night
you had a good time following Gerard
Carmichael he was great last night I
gotta ask you some other questions real
quick
okay
leave it on leave it on Lee because we
might play a video for people whatever
I was always the type of guy like
when
Ozzy left Sabbath yeah I made a
conscious decision not to like Sabbath
but
you had to be an idiot if you didn't you
weren't telling the truth yeah once you
heard Dio on that once I saw Dio in
Philadelphia
I had mixed emotions I'm not gonna lie
to you yeah you know Ozzy at the
Palladium was phenomenal okay
but I'm the type of guy like Santana you
sit there and go why didn't Santana be
make it because he never had the lead
singer yeah if Santana would have a lead
singer for 10 years you know you look at
Richie Blackmore with rainbow here's
another guy that went through singers on
every [__] album yeah he's a [__]
nightmare to work with you know that's
why I never liked him by the way yeah
cause I was a rainbow guy I liked him
with joling Guido Joe Lynn Turner Joe
and Turner I like them with the other
guy from Seattle
but I was never into these bands that
replaced the singer yeah I always
believed that
when a band replaced the singer the
singer brought in his own style a lot of
people always say to you but he sounds
just like [__] what's his name and
whatever I understand but
for me it was always bringing somebody
else
with a different sound then to sing the
songs that already been written whatever
okay now we have a sensitive subject
we have one of the best concerts I ever
saw emotion wise and what was going on
it was AC DC opening for Ted yeah all of
a sudden on my birthday me and my
buddies Louis castellito we do a hit
asses we're walking down Kenny Boulevard
with John Crowley and Rego and somebody
says did you hear the news Bond Scott
they found him in the car he's dead yeah
that was the anthem for me to AC DC but
again Back in Black
just so [__] good yeah it was so good
I think it got released like July of 81
or something 80 and 80 July of 80 and
the first show was in Philadelphia like
August 1st and the second show they took
it right to the Palladium yeah and my
friend this I just talked about this
with these guys last week the kid I went
when I went over with this kid Kurt and
we went to see uh this feed that we all
get what really pure Coke and he would
go crazy
AC DC was so phenomenal that night I
went home covered in the humidity that
was drenched from head to toe but that's
a completely different level you know
that I learned to love Brian Johnson
yeah I had so much stock
and Let There be Rock and power raids
yeah but I just couldn't let Brian
Johnson just stroll on the [__] set
you know yeah you gotta you gotta walk
this guy's footsteps okay I'm a power
rage [__] guy so day one you know
everybody waited everybody came off AC
DC and I went out I had heard I had a
friend who turned me on to power rage I
like the album cover yeah and it sent me
over the loop and consequently a few
weeks later hi where the hell was
released and right away everybody jumped
on the bandwagon they were opening for
Ted on the road Bon Scott was at his
height yeah Angus Young was at his
height yeah you know and all of a sudden
he dies again and I had too much
invested and here comes Brian Johnson
with a swab looks and his Guinea charm
now I'm doing The Godfather yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I love it uh and he
[__] uh takes over he wins over a
nation the album after that was called
what For Those About to Rock that album
right there that's when I tapped out
like I shoplifted down brought it home
with the cannon on it yep I robbed it
from Pathmark on Kennedy Boulevard I
brought him home listened to it I was
involved with maybe a week with it and
that was my end with with AC wow over
the years I heard Thunderstruck or
whatever yep was it a good song
yeah whatever it still wasn't walk all
over here yeah it still wasn't nobody
understands night probably what your
heart felt like when you heard when you
were in high school when you heard walk
all over you
my girl's just saying take it off take
it off we want Springsteen you're like
[__] you you dirty [__] yeah this is
staying on the only neighborhood that
has stayed on all the time was 64th
Street field they couldn't you know
those are the neighbors that chicks just
didn't talk they got beat up that's the
pride my friend Timmy has a present for
you like that when you go to New York
he's going to give it to you he's from
those projects yeah him and you were
gonna have a 10-hour conversation he'd
go he still goes to all the concerts ah
we were talking about him coming out for
Sabbath but it's the same week I'm in
New York oh wow so I basically he comes
out on [__] Monday to leave Tuesday
because I gotta go to work I gotta do
two [__] podcasts on Thursday
so we're talking about him coming out to
Chicago to shoot the special
shooting your special in Chicago yeah
October 15. oh bad ass we're at the Vic
the Rosemont Zanies oh badass right by
the airport there I'm in and out of that
I could snuggle with he's gonna eat 22
mushrooms yeah he's gonna be the master
ceremonies we're gonna call him Cap City
he's just gonna be eating cats he's
gonna have a little tuxedo my friend
started a tuxedo company for 99 you can
get a tuxedo online oh man Mike Rica so
we'll get you hooked up with a tuxedo
nicely you gotta drop another third you
gotta do a shot of deck of the Roblin
get your [__] pecs up you gotta look
sharp for this [__] CD I'm gonna talk
to the dude next week some dude hit me
with an email he's got a new type of
[__] he says he wants to put like a
beetle wig on you you know Michael
Jackson when it costs twenty thousand
dollars I'll give it to you for Gratis
just to talk about on the podcast what
an offer
he says he shaves your neck hair and
your back hand he makes like this little
head dude if he'll shave my back on a
weekly basis I'll do it nah like one
time they take all the hair off your
body they make the rig out of your hair
your own hair I I have a new back hair
every day if I look if I shave you this
has to be like a full-time thing
yeah this this we're talking about this
album right here I once got criticized
for putting one of this on Twitter
I put chains yeah
yeah somebody on Twitter but but this
album is 1976. it's a very hard album to
swallow but then again
you know this was at the time when they
were releasing this you know who else
came out that year speaking of queen
with the Death on Two Legs what's the
name of that Bohemian Rhapsody
what is that one uh the end of the world
or something what's it called uh
something world
what is it into the world Queen Bohemian
Rhapsody the end of the album no what is
it it's called
a News of the World News of the World
yes that's a great you know all these
albums are coming up but people don't
remember is that [__] Elton John was
throwing [__] heat the guy was
killing guys Elton John was killing it
this is such a [__] a long time that
it took you know him and then Paul
McCartney started coming around with his
[__] [__] and his [__] was priceless
banned on the run and jet and all that
[__] but man Queen it's crazy like I'll
go through these Queen phases where I'll
just listen to Queen and I'll be like
this is like nobody was doing that [__]
man Bohemian Rhapsody you had to be
doing some mushrooms to come up with all
that God
first time I heard that I was in the
Blimpy base oh
I'm like 30 something Street and Kennedy
and Bergenline Avenue we had we used to
go up there we used to take a two-way
hitter uh and what you did was you put
it was a pipe it was a glass pipe with a
hole in it you put the joint in there
and you put your hand on it yeah and you
sucked it in yeah and we got so [__]
stoned and we went into this Blimpy base
I got a roast beef with provolone nice
we've been together
lettuce some tomatoes and onions nice
with some wise potato chips
and I [__] started we got the giggles
we got him when he said Mama Mia Mama
Mia let me go we [__] got the case of
the giggles and the guy threw us out
with all our sandwiches I'm still pissed
at that [__] he's probably a
general manager somewhere right now
eating good you know what I remember
about that man never saw a Queen live I
like this
I was at the mall I used to go to the
mall uh like on the weekends you know
and there was the new store it opened
the good guys it was new at the time
good guys it's electronic store you know
and they had about a hundred TV screens
and the laser disc had just came out the
LaserDisc and the [__] guy put it in
and we walked by and every screen had
this queen LaserDisc playing and and we
stopped and we were in there for an hour
just like whoa laser disc it was like
futuristic [__] man the guy put in this
big disc and we were watching Queen do
that video where it's the foreheads
oh they had a couple jams when I was
growing up by the way Lee those
mushrooms are kicking and heavy right
yeah yeah kicking the door waving the
4-4
hey let me tell you something Joe
there's a clip I want you to see because
I don't think people understand the
impact of Brian Johnson uh put in AC DC
Japan Back in Black uh this is very rare
footage of them on the back and black
tour it's really hard to find footage of
them on this tour and this is in Japan
and you see Bryant not there keep going
let me see here any [__] 60 years ago
yeah uh
punch it in on YouTube
AC DC in Japan yeah Back in Black tour
put in AC DC Japan because this is Brian
before the Hat you know if if you look
at them on the back of the right he had
the big hair he's wearing like a
football jersey let's check it out there
it is right there 81 Tokyo look at this
this [__]
like you could see how he won it over
[Music]
[Applause]
check out Brian here it's a big old hair
you can barely hear these guitars
[Music]
unbelievable this footage
yeah he won him over he really did he's
killing he really did win them over look
how good he sounds
it was a complete different band totally
it was a complete different band you
forgot about Bon Scott that's crazy I
did I didn't either but I'm just because
this album ripped new fans yeah chicken
Lee kick it listen to this vocal
we gotta tell you
another round
[Music]
look at that yeah unbelievable
unbelievable
[Applause]
[Music]
totally different Brian Johnson he's got
moves he's out front his hair is rocking
[Applause]
1980 babe you gotta bring it get [__]
bring it they're [__] bringing it
right now
[Music]
the screams coming out of here are
insane watch when he hits these notes
oh Angus just [__] like 20 something
you know here he goes listen to Brian
here
[Music]
oh
blowing my mind guys
insane
it really really well look at this [__]
what's this
the reason why his hair is like that he
didn't have time to get a haircut
when they got rolling guys it was they
schemed a few Americans and you don't
open for them that August before who'd
you have I had Nantucket
oh you got lucky I'll do this
that first battle oh yeah on through the
night they sang a couple songs oh yeah
yeah like two or three songs yeah Lions
rise wow think of what this concert was
for me this was too much but again like
you really like
I'm still not even sold on Guns and
Roses like I'm still not sold on it wow
yeah I'm still not sold on it I really
don't want to see Axel Rose singing ACD
oh have you watched any of it yet no
really yeah you haven't no it was the
second it happened I was up at like you
know because it was in Europe so I was
just I was I got home from The Comedy
Store and he immediately fired it out
listen we're living in a society that
nobody's gonna tell you the shows suck
because yeah
this is completely out of the norm with
what's going on with music today like
this is these these these kind of bands
are not around today you have a
different vibe that they got you know
there what do they call those kids
hipsters and they have tight pants and
everything is a look this is music oh
this is you know this is these guys look
like a bomb [__] hit him dude I mean
the energy right there the energy is
[__] you know and this is an arena
guys this isn't uh you know some [__]
real with 800 people these guys were
blowing I'll never forget leaving that
well why saw him it wasn't [__]
what the Palladium seat in New York City
what's the Palladium seat New York City
1980 yeah I don't know but we can uh we
can Google that [__] Lee knows
everything we can find your social
security number he can find out what you
waited Bert Palladium capacity in New
York City
so there it is right there Wikipedia oh
I think it's at 7 000.
uh
uh right there three thousand yeah three
thousand major venue New York City rock
rock and roll
can you look at that let me see I count
the music he's from 14th Street the
venue
rock concerts in the early among those
were the Rolling Stone 65. yeah this is
uh the band oh that's where they uh did
uh recorded their live record wow Blue
Oyster Cult Iggy Pop kiss John Lennon
Genesis that's an epic epic spot
Grateful Dead played two extended stands
at the vineyard seven shows straight
wow I saw I was very fortunate to see
them there I saw Iron Maiden there with
Paul diano it's like The Clash played
there I saw it I think I saw James Brown
there I think I saw I know for a fact I
saw Ozzy Osbourne there yeah I saw a
couple good [__] shows there man [__]
Springsteen Palladium I never saw
Springsteen 76 dude and 78. wow it had
it when you were outside the place yeah
and had that feeling I love that it's
like being outside the garden if you
ever went to the Garden in here when you
walk a block away from the garden people
already hitting you for tickets you can
feel the electricity people people are
walking with like a ghetto Boombox
playing to that album like I still
remember walk you know taking the bus to
see AC DC opening up for dead like you
had to be there by 801 that's when the
show started [__] yeah and getting on
the train and people with [__] ghetto
blasters listen to my way to Hell meet D
Agostino this kid not the deal just you
know today this kid the Agostino I grew
up with his sister we shed lockers and
me him and this kid named Randy and
Miracle got him rest assault one of the
toughest white dudes ever we took a bus
from Jersey North Bergen from Union City
all the way down to uh Seaside Heights
and
we [__] uh he refused to take that
off we did a hitter asset oh yeah and he
kept putting AC DC and he kept flipping
it uh he kept putting on the highway to
hell and flipping it over to AC DC the
Australian release oh yeah yeah yeah TNT
TNT with soul stripper I know all that
[__] Squealer you know how many times
the bus driver pulled over
I said the next time he turned that on
we're throwing you off the bus and again
we do it and again and that's the oh my
God I I it's it's
you you're sad you're sad that you
didn't really uh put those moments on
tape like that's what I always tell my
friends when I talk to him now I said
I'm really sad that I didn't think I had
a box I didn't have a camera oh you know
crazy you're [__] terrible somebody
taped
the uh Pink Floyd show I was at it's on
it's on whatever it's not a great taping
but it's really sad that we didn't even
tape taking the bus over or the people
who hung out in the city in those days
the people that would trade you seats
yeah there were people that would trade
you see so what do you got you got 12 I
got six bro let me get that in twenty
dollars where you just bought
counterfeit tickets you stupid
[__] you got [__] [__] if
you're walking to the [__] garden
with tickets in your hand keep them yeah
you don't gotta talk to nobody you don't
know how many times my friends have come
up to me we scored sixth row yeah we
gave them our tickets in 10 bucks and
I'm like oh Jesus the next day at school
you're not gonna believe it they were
[__] daisies they were fake [__]
tickets that one and the three card
Molly the guys who gets you with man my
buddy got nailed on that in front of uh
Judas Priest man we're out there Henry J
Kaiser the guy they got the setup dude
you don't know and he walks up puts down
20 and wins a hundred really
I saw where the card is I'm in and he
does it and now he can't buy a jersey
because he [__] lost his money the
shirts were twenty dollars twenty bucks
I paid 15 for the Pink Floyd yeah
they're like 10 bucks yeah that I had a
Pink Floyd baseball t-shirt yeah it was
the colored sleeves jerseys with the
thing that shirt lasted for six or seven
years even the logo in front like I
finally lost it yeah
I'd wear them till they disintegrate
those kinds of t-shirts were your badge
of on you know it's that walk into the
office every day with your little
Starbucks cup and you're thinking Johnny
Bananas in the in those days when you
went to a concert if you didn't wear the
Constitution
what do you mean one day the next day oh
yeah the next day Church yeah a [__]
funeral yeah a fourth a First Communion
yeah you wore that shirt if you went
through it constantly whether it was
tall whoever you bought a t-shirt and
you wore that [__] to school the
next day and you were proud you were
like [__] this [__] it was the only
place you could get a shirt yeah you
couldn't get a Hot Topic there's no Hot
Topic go down hey look at this you got
the shirt and you walked onto the campus
at school and people were like you went
last night
forbid somebody bought you a shirt oh
and you didn't go to the car oh that was
sacrifice guys used to go we buy me a
shirt I'd be like no
no I ain't getting your Olympic medals
it's crazy because now when you go to
Walmart in like Kentucky or yeah in the
small City like a big seven bucks they
have all those like Led Zeppelin that's
reunion to the one tour yeah the devil
whatever they have them in all those
stores if you go to not Walmart but the
other one Target
Target's got it Target which one Kmart
one of those stores Kmart and Target
have all Targets
every vintage t-shirt when I see Justin
Bieber with a vintage [__] Metallica
shirt Metallica shirt or something I
want to punch him in the mouth because I
stood online oh yeah you know I did acid
I I sacrificed the job [__] you I'm not
coming in tomorrow we gotta drive to
Philadelphia yep you know you put all
this effort into going to concerts and
also you get these Johnny come lately
that paint their [__] hell down and
they wear the concert T-shirt that's how
against we were fake people in those
days that's true like this is why I get
so offended today because
I see all these people that are just
walking around they haven't earned the
right to do this [__] like they really
haven't because people really haven't
I would ask the guy hey would they play
for the Encore they go oh oh man I was
[__] up it's like no no you weren't
there dude because you would know if
they played for the Encore everybody
knows the Encore yeah you know they'd be
like [__] dude they came out they did
Let There be Rock that's the first thing
you told people yeah that night when you
bumped into people at the bar what was
the Encore oh [__] you [__] up they
were tremendous yeah dog they went on
they did three [__] on calls like I
still remember going to see the new
Barbarians at the Garden that's cool
they did a bunch of encores yeah and
like being so happy and they did you
know you know what sugar sugar yeah rock
and roll yeah whenever they do those
encores those super bands yeah yeah they
do like a 50s tune they're like come on
it drives me crazy right at the end of
these award ceremonies I just do the
rummy jam oh it drives me [__] right
they all got like that stupid look on
their face and then there's Paul
Schaefer over there yeah triggering the
soul was you got this one man you got
this one you know
actually died no he's still alive I saw
him last week I almost [__] threw the
TV out let me give some shout out so we
can get you out of here I love you dude
hey man what a great episode Memorial
Day weekend just talking music oh
honesty about music I want to give a
shout out to David Rubin
my man Jeffrey Collins my man Scott
Hughes Chris Murphy BJJ cardio kid dig a
smart
alibaz my girl [__] lady Jay I
haven't seen her on Twitter get your
[__] together watch that monkey my main
girl Oogie's spooky my my [__] peeps
in Austin and [__] Tommy Easter Digger
smart Paul Perez
Glenn Collins and cheeseburger Dan I
love you [__]
don't forget I will be at the Omaha
Funny Bone June 10th and 11th and I'll
be at the Philadelphia helium throwing
some [__] heat June 20 something 20
something 20 something go on that
webpage what are you bothering me for
I'm doing uh Comedy Works five nights
headlining Fourth of July weekend June
uh 28th through July 2nd it's a great
club and people go out there and [__]
seeing me Reef heads please do it man
bring him reefer he'll bring it back to
me yeah I will and then come out and see
me and also uh I got an excellent
podcast dropping tomorrow with uh Tim
Bloom from the Mother Hips and uh and
shout out to Greg Riley from El Cajon
Harley he's a big fan of the church and
a good friend of mine yeah it's funny I
was going to try to get you on with uh
missing person yeah
yeah and I keep forgetting to hit him up
he's right here in Van Nuys and listens
to the podcast great kid you know I see
his tweets yeah he hit me up he's got a
band you know uh
what happens is that is he still alive
yeah I talked to him I said can we get
your dad on I saw your dad at the US
Festival and uh your dad's one of the
first like really super drummers that
put had the the instructional videos and
stuff and he said he's gonna try he said
his dad is kind of um an introvert now
stays in stays in in the house you know
it doesn't go out much and I was like uh
well sometimes a podcast will jump start
somebody's life they get out and they do
the podcast and they start interacting
on social media yeah social media
exactly and they go hey man [__] this is
great and Lee great to see you dude
I love you seeing anything yet Lee I
know I'm feeling a lot of [__] but I
don't see nothing what do you feel what
do you feel um
I'm doing a lot of [__] when you say
teeth floating I think I feel what you
mean look at somebody's got a good
picture of me on on Twitter look at that
that's my man that's my man one by one
Bobcat yeah what kind of chocolate
cookies
oh my god
um someone
hey uh before we get out I want to leave
one note for you I really think Lee fire
up this band just one second because I
want you to hear it you don't want to
write no more at least like I'm done
only one type enough I can't one second
what cookies you got Lee okay well
flavor so Steve and Amanda
if they listen to this podcast but they
listen to good times with Steve Simone
and he was in Edmonton and they gave him
these uh chocolate
cookies and they I think they have
Reese's Pieces in there so you're gonna
[__] break one out yeah we're gonna
leave one all of a sudden I'm too high
to do that trust me you need a piece of
cookie and you need to calm that Dragon
down a little bit tell me why do you
think I'm [__] suggesting it for my
health daily uh tomorrow
is Memorial Day You're gonna be sitting
there with your family and [__] thinking
about your [__] pathetic life for two
minutes think about the [__] people
who got in a [__] plane or a boat
and go to a foreign land and stab
[__] for you if you ever think
about that you [__]
every day put the [__] national
anthem only that's it give me one of
those [__] cookies
I'm getting emotional here we get the
cookie for himself you forget somebody
[Music]
started from scratching
tell me when you're ready hit it
[Music]
this 2016 Memorial Day don't think of
yourself when you're in the barbecue
thinking about what people brought this
guy brought Donuts this guy brought
steaks this guy brought chicken this guy
didn't bring that what [__] did you
bring what the [__] did you bring
to take a boat a boat and go over there
[__] Vietnamese people did you go
over there and [__] fight the Nazis
did you go over there and fight the
Cubans or what the [__] did you do you
hanging out at Starbucks bad mouthing
your country sticking up patronies and
[__] [__] you [__] tomorrow's
the day that's where you stick up for
but you forget that [__] you forget it
when you eat your gluten [__] free
pasta and your [__] Apple [__]
whatever [__] yourself [__] think
of the people of their families and [__]
me I never win I can never jump a fence
tomorrow think about
[Music]
the Box
before you eat your [__] cheeseburger
you worthless [__] I love America
thank you for coming on tonight my
brothers
I'm high as [__] and that's all that
matters you understand me
these are pretty good cookies right yeah
they're gonna tame the [__] spider
you understand me then you don't want
this [__] spider getting a hold of me
and as usual
one of my newest sponsors and I loved it
to death that's usara
you know what it means to leave the
salary work is life to fulfill life
that's what it [__] means that's what
this whole label means they sent me a
box of stuff okay I've been wearing the
sweatshirt to jiu jitsu they have a
[__] fanny pack they have a bag that
is tremendous you can hold your water
your bandages your wallets your phones
your keys it has a little bag in there
to put your [__] rash guard and your
stinky socks and your underwears and
along with your ghee I mean they got
they got t-shirts they got shorts do me
a favor
go to dsgear.com and look at the great
selection of stuff they have okay they
got a hemp give listen when I lose 20
pounds you're gonna see me flying
through the air with this [__]
beautiful hem gee that they got they
don't [__] around it's comfortable it
just doesn't fit around my stomach but
give me a couple weeks but anyway do me
a favor today go to dsgear.com right now
again that's DS Capital gear
g-e-a-r.com take a look at the bags take
a look at the fanny packs take a look at
the hoodies take a look at the geese and
if you like something do me a favor go
to the box impression church
c-h-u-r-ch and get five percent off your
first order right again go to DS gear
g-e-a-r.com and look at the great
selection of clothing lines and
everything that they have I love this
guy uh Chris so listen great customer
service if you have any problems get
back to me dot susara you understand me
to leave the salary workers life like
stop being a peasant take a chance
Columbus did God sucker all right I love
you Dean thank you for being my [__]
rock Mogul dude keeping me alive I'm
talking about music man we could talk
for hours it's just incredible it's just
it I mean it's just like old days just
doing coke and in the living room and
just go what about this record man
there's nothing like that
thanks for coming on don't forget
Omaha next week
and then Philadelphia
I don't know the dates I'm [__] up
what do you want from me have a great
holiday stay black
I love it
[Music]
blood
foreign
[Music]
thank you